Medir uma superposição quântica é tão aleatório quanto jogar uma moeda, mas até onde podemos levar essa
analogia antes que ela se rompa? Vamos descobrir hoje no Qiskit na
Sala de Aula. Bem-vindo ao Qiskit na Sala de Aula, uma série de vídeos onde destrinchamos um conceito fundamental que você
pode encontrar num curso relacionado à Computação Quântica. Cada vídeo é acompanhado por um módulo interativo com link na
descrição abaixo, então não deixa de conferir. Hoje estamos falando sobre um dos princípios fundamentais no coração da
teoria quântica: a superposição. Na nossa experiência cotidiana, os objetos sempre têm características definidas — sua localização, tamanho,
forma, cor — tudo sobre eles é determinado e certo, mesmo que nós, os observadores, ainda não tenhamos medido isso. No
mundo quântico, isso não é necessariamente o caso. Um objeto quântico pode estar em algo chamado superposição de
múltiplos estados clássicos permitidos, que quando medido vai colapsar aleatoriamente para um desses
estados. Medir um estado de superposição é como jogar uma moeda: não há como saber com antecedência para que lado ela vai
cair. Esse indeterminismo fundamental é um aspecto desconfortável da mecânica quântica com o qual até mesmo Einstein teve problemas.
Ele disse famosamente "Deus não joga dados" sobre essa aleatoriedade. Mas, como veremos, Deus de fato joga dados — ou, no
nosso caso, joga moedas. Mas tem mais: essas moedas são viciadas. Medir uma superposição quântica pode ser similar a
jogar uma moeda em alguns aspectos, mas a superposição em si é muito mais rica e complexa do que um estado
probabilístico clássico. Para ver isso, vamos pensar em como uma moeda clássica funciona e contrastar com a nossa
moeda quântica que exploraremos usando o Qiskit num computador quântico da IBM. Primeiro, uma moeda clássica. É
bem simples: você joga a moeda e ela cai cara para cima ou cara para baixo com 50% de chance para cada lado. Bem, em princípio, poderíamos
calcular qual lado a moeda vai cair se soubéssemos as condições iniciais precisas da moeda e exatamente quanta
força e torque foram aplicados durante o lançamento. Mas na prática, não há como saber a priori para que lado a
moeda vai cair. Por isso usamos o lançamento de moeda como exemplo canônico de um estado probabilístico clássico, onde o
resultado é essencialmente aleatório. Se eu jogasse essa moeda mil vezes e registrasse o número de caras para cima
e caras para baixo, obteria um histograma que se parece com isso. Então temos contagens no eixo Y
e pode ser cara para cima ou cara para baixo, e o
histograma mostraria que há cerca de 500 contagens de cada, sujeitas a alguma
flutuação estatística. Podemos criar um estado similar usando um qubit no nosso computador quântico. Assim como o lançamento de moeda, um
qubit também pode ser medido em dois estados possíveis: zero e um. Se aplicarmos algo chamado gate Hadamard ao
qubit, ele ficará numa superposição igual de zero e um. Aqui está uma
visualização desse circuit, chamada diagrama de circuit. O fio do topo é o
qubit e as operações aplicadas ao qubit aparecem como caixas nos fios. O gate Hadamard é mostrado com esta caixa
com rótulo H, e a medição é mostrada com esta caixa cinza com o pequeno símbolo de medição. Ela envia esse resultado
para um bit clássico — esse fio com duas linhas. Então, como o qubit está numa superposição igual de 0 e um, quando
medimos, haverá 50% de chance de medirmos zero e 50% de medirmos
um. Expressamos esse estado de superposição quântica como s = 1/√2 |0⟩ + 1/√2 |1⟩
onde os quadrados de cada um desses coeficientes — também chamados de amplitudes — são as probabilidades de medir cada estado. Então, na prática, aplicar o gate Hadamard
é análogo a jogar uma moeda. E assim como jogamos a moeda mil vezes para ver as
estatísticas de a moeda cair cara para cima ou cara para baixo, podemos fazer algo similar no Qiskit com nossa moeda quântica.
Vamos usar um primitivo do Qiskit chamado Sampler, que vai repetir o circuit várias vezes para amostrar as estatísticas
do estado resultante. Com mil amostras do circuit acima, temos algo basicamente idêntico
ao histograma da moeda clássica, sujeito a alguma flutuação estatística. Então é isso? As superposições quânticas
são essencialmente iguais a um estado probabilístico clássico, análogas ao lançamento de uma moeda? Não exatamente. Isso seria
um vídeo bem curto se fosse o caso. Para ver a nossa primeira diferença chave, vou tentar algo ligeiramente diferente com a minha moeda clássica: em vez
de simplesmente deixá-la cair na mesa, caindo cara para cima ou para baixo, vou jogá-la e pegá-la
no ar entre as palmas das mãos. Agora a moeda não está cara para cima ou para baixo, mas sim ora cara para a esquerda
ou para a direita. Então a lógica nos diz que isso também deve ter uma probabilidade de 50/50 de ser
cara para a esquerda ou para a direita. Para medir cara para a esquerda ou para a direita na nossa moeda quântica, podemos fazer o que fizemos com a moeda clássica:
medir ao longo de um eixo diferente. As nossas medições padrão no computador quântico são ao longo do eixo vertical,
assim como a medição usual de cara para cima ou para baixo da moeda clássica. Mas também podemos perguntar à nossa moeda quântica se está
cara para a esquerda ou para a direita. Chamamos esses dois estados ao longo do eixo X de mais ou menos.
Para isso, usamos o primitivo do Qiskit chamado Estimator. Para complicar um pouco as coisas, em vez de retornar um histograma como
o Sampler faz, o Estimator nos dará o chamado valor esperado de qualquer observável do qubit. Para
entender esse valor esperado, digamos que você ganha um dólar toda vez que a moeda cai cara para cima e perde um dólar quando ela
cai cara para baixo. O valor esperado é quanto dinheiro você pode esperar ganhar na média com cada lançamento. Como você tem
igual probabilidade de ganhar ou perder um dólar, o valor esperado seria zero. O mesmo raciocínio pode ser aplicado
ao qubit. Quando encontramos o valor esperado de X, ao aplicar X ao estado mais, obtemos
o valor +1; e ao estado menos, obtemos −1. Então, se tivéssemos uma distribuição de 50/50,
obteríamos um valor esperado de zero. Mas não obtemos: obtemos um valor esperado de +1,
o que significa que a moeda é sempre medida como mais ao longo do eixo X. Isso seria como jogar uma
moeda, pegá-la e garantir que a cara sempre estivesse voltada para a direita. Isso ocorre porque uma
superposição não é apenas uma distribuição de probabilidade. Lembra como expressamos um estado quântico
s como C₀ vezes o estado 0 mais C₁
vezes o estado 1, onde cada um desses coeficientes é complexo, ou seja,
têm partes reais e imaginárias? Eles nos dizem as probabilidades, mas também ocultam outra grandeza chamada
fase. Algum coeficiente C pode ser escrito
assim, onde C é igual à magnitude vezes essa fase, onde esse φ é a
fase. É um pouco como a fase de uma onda, ou a localização das cristas e dos vales de uma onda. Se duas ondas estão em fase
entre si — ou seja, suas cristas e vales se alinham —, elas vão se combinar para formar uma onda duas vezes
maior. Chamamos isso de interferência construtiva. Se estão fora de fase,
assim, elas interferem destrutivamente, se cancelando completamente. Para ver como a fase pode causar
interferência na nossa moeda quântica, vamos tentar aplicar o gate Hadamard duas vezes em vez de apenas uma. Agora classicamente
isso não faria sentido algum: se aplicar o gate Hadamard é equivalente a jogar uma moeda, não se pode jogar uma moeda que já está sendo jogada. Mas vamos ver o que
acontece quanticamente. Aplicamos o gate Hadamard duas vezes e amostramos o estado resultante.
Surpreendentemente, não temos mais uma probabilidade de 50/50. O histograma resultante mostra que em todos os casos medimos o
qubit no estado zero. Então o segundo gate Hadamard retornou o qubit ao estado zero de onde partimos. É
um pouco difícil de ver no começo, mas isso ocorre graças à interferência do estado quântico. Porém, em vez de
interferir no espaço real como uma onda real, a interferência acontece no espaço de informação abstrato do qubit.
O segundo gate Hadamard fez com que a parte zero da superposição interferisse construtivamente, enquanto a parte um da
superposição interferiu destrutivamente e desapareceu. Vamos explorar mais. Podemos mudar a fase usando
algo chamado gate de fase. Então, agora, vamos aplicar um gate Hadamard para criar a superposição, aplicar um deslocamento de fase de
π radianos e depois aplicar o segundo gate Hadamard. Agora parece que a nossa moeda quântica sempre sai no estado um.
O deslocamento de fase de π trocou as partes do estado de superposição que estavam em fase e fora de fase entre si,
então o estado final é um em vez de zero. Isso seria como jogar uma moeda e, enquanto ela estivesse no ar, ser capaz de
aplicar de alguma forma uma operação que garantiria que ela sempre caísse cara para cima ou sempre cara para baixo, dependendo da
operação. Impossível no caso clássico, mas não no caso quântico. O que aprendemos com esses experimentos é
que essa nova capacidade da moeda quântica se deve à sua fase — uma qualidade que uma superposição quântica tem, mas uma
distribuição de probabilidade clássica não tem. Então o lançamento de moeda usual na verdade não é uma boa analogia para uma
superposição porque não diz nada sobre essa fase. Acho que podemos fazer melhor. Vou fazer outro
experimento com a nossa moeda. Tenho a moeda em cima da mesa, cara para cima. Para virar para cara para baixo, posso simplesmente girá-la.
Isso é o equivalente computacional de um gate NOT. Digamos que queremos construir uma operação que, se aplicada duas vezes, seria
equivalente a esse gate NOT. Podemos chamar essa operação de raiz quadrada do NOT. Pensa no que estamos fisicamente fazendo
quando aplicamos o gate NOT: estamos rotacionando 180° em torno de, por exemplo, o eixo X. Então, se rotacionássemos a moeda
apenas 90° em torno do eixo X, isso nos daria a raiz quadrada do NOT. Então aplicamos
nossa raiz quadrada do NOT e a moeda fica apoiada na borda. Agora podemos perguntar: está cara para cima ou cara para baixo? Bem,
claramente não está nem um nem outro. Mas poderíamos adicionar uma etapa ao processo de medição para forçá-la a ser cara para cima ou cara para baixo. Agora a
moeda cairá para cara para cima ou cara para baixo com igual probabilidade. De novo, em princípio poderíamos prever
para qual lado vai cair, mas na prática isso é difícil o suficiente para prever que torna o resultado essencialmente aleatório. Se eu quiser
medir se está cara para a esquerda ou direita, posso esmagar nessa direção de forma similar, e isso novamente nos dará uma
probabilidade de 50/50 de esquerda e direita. Mas nessa dimensão — cara para frente ou para trás —,
a cara já está voltada para frente, então 100% do tempo mediremos cara para frente. Portanto, enquanto as medições em X e Z
produziram resultados aleatórios, a medição em Y sempre produzirá o mesmo resultado. Se pensarmos no experimento da moeda quântica
da seção anterior, isso lembra como a moeda quântica se comportou depois de aplicar o gate Hadamard: o qubit era medido como zero ou 1 com probabilidade de 50/50 na direção Z, mas
sempre o estado mais e nunca o estado menos ao longo de X. Isso sugere que talvez uma moeda parada em sua borda
seja uma maneira melhor de visualizar um estado de superposição de um qubit do que uma moeda girando descontroladamente no ar.
Vamos aplicar um gate de raiz quadrada do NOT à nossa moeda quântica no Qiskit. Temos este circuit simples.
Depois, vamos usar o Estimator para checar o valor esperado dos três observáveis X, Y e Z, que são como
colapsar nossa moeda ao longo de cada uma das três dimensões, como acabei de mostrar. Então os valores esperados são 0,
−1 e 0 para X, Y e Z respectivamente. Este é o mesmo resultado que
obtivemos para a rotação de raiz quadrada do NOT aplicada à moeda clássica. Na verdade, há uma analogia precisa entre a
moeda e o estado do qubit. Agora podemos visualizar o estado do qubit como um vetor apontando na direção da cara
da moeda, perpendicular à superfície da moeda. Então, cara para cima, ou o estado zero
na moeda quântica, é equivalente a um vetor apontando diretamente para cima. Cara para baixo, ou um, está apontando diretamente para baixo. E qualquer
superposição igual de 0 e um aponta horizontalmente. A fase do estado quântico determina a direção horizontal exata para a qual aponta —
por exemplo, se está apontando ao longo do eixo X, ao longo do eixo Y ou em algum ponto entre eles.
Esse vetor é conhecido como vetor de Bloch e determina completa e unicamente o estado quântico de um único
qubit. Agora podemos reimaginar cada gate que vimos neste vídeo como uma rotação ou uma série de rotações na
moeda, ou de forma equivalente no vetor de Bloch. O gate NOT é uma rotação de
180° em torno do eixo X. Quando aplicado ao nosso estado zero, ou cara para cima, ele vira para o
estado para baixo, ou um. A raiz quadrada do NOT é apenas 90° em torno do mesmo eixo X. Começando
do estado cara para cima, isso o rotaciona para cara para frente. Um gate de fase é uma rotação de φ em torno do eixo Z. Como
cara para cima está alinhado com o eixo Z, isso não faz nada à moeda. O gate Hadamard é um pouco mais complicado. Inicialmente
o comparamos a jogar uma moeda, fazendo a moeda girar descontrolavelmente no ar. Mas o gate Hadamard é na verdade uma
cara para cima está alinhado com o eixo Z, isso não faz nada com a moeda. O gate Hadamard é um pouco mais complicado, nós
inicialmente o comparamos a jogar uma moeda, fazendo a moeda girar incontrolavelmente no ar, mas o Hadamard é na verdade uma
rotação controlada e determinística da moeda, como todos os outros gates. O Hadamard é realizado girando 90°
é cara para a direita. Então, não há nada de aleatório num estado de superposição quântica ou em qualquer uma das
operações padrão que realizamos no qubit. Cada operação é determinística e reversível. A única
vez que a aleatoriedade entra em jogo é quando decidimos medir o estado quântico. Se um estado quântico está sequer em uma
superposição é realmente uma questão de ponto de vista. Como você já deve ter encontrado, somos livres para escolher o nosso
sistema de coordenadas: X, Y e Z podem apontar ao longo de quaisquer três direções ortogonais. Então,
se temos uma superposição de 0 e 1 num sistema de coordenadas, podemos definir um novo sistema de coordenadas, ou uma nova
base chamada, no qual o estado aponta puramente na direção +Z e, portanto, não está num estado de superposição.
Então, quando dizemos que um qubit está em superposição, também devemos definir o nosso sistema de coordenadas ou
base. Você pode sair deste módulo com a impressão de que acabamos de remover todo o mistério da mecânica quântica.
Afinal, um dos aspectos supostamente mais estranhos — o estado de superposição de um qubit — é na verdade tão simples quanto um
vetor tridimensional. Mas lembra que a moeda ainda é apenas uma analogia, e mesmo o vetor de Bloch é
apenas uma ferramenta de visualização. Para calcular as probabilidades dos resultados das medições, não podemos dizer o que um estado quântico
está realmente fazendo antes de ser medido, porque verificar isso requer uma medição. Vamos discutir
esse dilema sobre qual é a verdadeira natureza de um estado quântico, e como o fenômeno quântico do entrelaçamento pode nos ajudar a
elucidar isso em outro episódio do Qiskit na Sala de Aula, todo sobre a desigualdade de Bell. Enquanto isso, se você
quiser brincar com moedas quânticas para aprender por conta própria sobre os estados de superposição de um qubit e como controlá-los,
acessa o módulo de moedas quânticas com link na descrição. Obrigado por assistir e até a próxima!